the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video in this
video i will show you what mazie
williams recently had to say about not
only game of thrones but house of the
dragon as well also later in the same
video i will show you what nikolai
coster waldow said about house of the
dragon in one of his recent interviews i
know there are some of you who always
like hearing what some of the older game
of thrones actors have to say these days
i know i always find it interesting even
if their answers don't always reveal how
they actually feel
now first let me show you what maisie
williams said during her interview at
variety in this interview they asked her
how she feels about the different scenes
that she filmed on game of thrones they
asked her this because of something
sophie recently said about her scenes as
i'm sure most of you know by now maisie
and sophie basically became real life
sisters while working on game of thrones
in fact they're still great friends to
this day well sophie recently said that
working on certain scenes in game of
thrones was traumatic for her in ways
that she still has to comprehend
so the interviewer asked maisie if she
felt the same way about any of the
scenes she was in during game of thrones
they wondered if she looks back on her
scenes differently now that she's a
little bit older maisie williams said i
don't find the scenes that i shot on
game of thrones and the nature of the
violence and the descent into obsession
over the list of names that she wants to
kill i didn't necessarily find that
traumatic to do i think i just found you
know growing well i'm not gonna say that
i did not find those scenes traumatic to
do
after hearing about this i did wonder
what scene sophie was referring to now
if i had to guess i would say the scene
she filmed with ramsay on their wedding
night had to be one of the hardest
scenes to be in
filming something like that especially
at such a young age must have affected
her in some way
obviously i'm not the one who should be
discussing something like this so i will
move on to the next thing that was
mentioned during the interview
maisie was also asked if she still talks
to anyone she worked with on the show
she said everyone we're all on a group
chat which is lovely everyone's doing
really well and i think that it's nice
to keep up with them while they're
enjoying their lives which had been
dominated by the show for so long
now that is certainly nice to hear i
like knowing that they're all still
friends even now three years after the
show has ended i don't know about all of
you but i still get excited whenever i
see someone from game of thrones in a
new show or movie i'm about to watch
alright now this is when they ask her if
she will be watching house of the dragon
maisie said yes i'm really looking
forward to it actually my friend olivia
who we all know as allison hightower is
in the show and it's been really
interesting just chatting to her about
the experience i think it's actually a
lot more pressure for them all of the
hungover concerns of our show are now
just being thrown onto this new cast who
had nothing to do with it i want to be
as supportive as i can to her as an
actress but also i'm just really curious
i'm kind of looking forward to watching
game of thrones even though it's not
actually game of thrones i want to
experience it as someone that's not on
it all i've done is meet fans who have
done just that and i never really was
able to relate to it well maisy is
definitely right about one thing old
fans of game of thrones are worried that
the same mistakes will be made on house
of the dragon which isn't entirely fair
considering dan and dave no longer work
for hbo this is a new show with new
writers that already has an amazing
ending written by george rr martin in
another recent interview maisie said she
would consider stepping back into the
role as arya stark someday and that made
a lot of news the interviewer wanted to
know if that news did surprise her
maisie said no are you kidding me i
haven't given anyone anything else to
talk about yet that's what everyone
wants from me but they're not gonna get
it until the time is right
it's nice to know what they want from
you even if it's not what you're ready
to give
now maybe i am wrong about this but it
does seem like maisy would be arya stark
again i bet a lot of the old game of
thrones actors would step back into
westeros again for most of them it will
be the most successful thing they will
ever work on now i'm sure by the end of
season 8 some of them did want a break
from the show but now that we're three
years separated from the ending some of
them would most likely jump at the
chance at joining hbo again for another
incredible run
now what they discuss next is how maisie
williams is very selective about what
she says during her interviews
especially whenever game of thrones is
mentioned
in fact maisie actually admits that she
does do this which we all knew already
almost everyone does this whenever
they're giving an interview now what
they ask her after this is why she does
that what is she worried about saying
regarding game of thrones
they say it seems like maybe you don't
want to be the center of a negative
story about the show given how everyone
talked about it at the very end
obviously there was a lot of negative
feedback after the final season aired
maisie said no i don't want to defend
the show for that reason i don't really
i don't really mind that it ended that
way
we were so disconnected from i felt like
my life and how it changed was so
disconnected from the actual storyline
of the show it was getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and you couldn't go anywhere and you
couldn't you know sleep on an airplane
or whatever and then it ended and it was
we can breathe
and when everyone was like but we hate
the ending it was just kind of like well
it's nice for it to be done and to
actually find some kind of normal life i
feel like i would have felt like that
even if it had an amazing ending you
know now that very last sentence makes
it sound as if she doesn't think it
already had an amazing ending let's look
at that last line again maisie said i
feel like i would have felt like that
even if it had an amazing ending you
know
well as we all know she certainly would
not be the first actor from game of
thrones who felt that way we have all
seen more than enough video evidence to
know how some of them actually felt have
you shot your final scenes yet and are
you happy with how things ended
yes
she didn't say yes you didn't say that
best season ever
without telling us anything i know you
can't is are you all happy with the way
your things end with the outcome of the
show
it's a little bit avengers assembly it's
a little bit kind of like well that was
totally what season seven was all about
exactly character development
love it all right
[Laughter]
let's move on and see what our old
friend jamie lannister said about house
of the dragon
now i'll be the first to say he did not
say much about the new show but i will
show you what he said anyway game of
thrones star nikolai koster-waldau is
curious to revisit westeros when the new
series house of the dragon airs on hbo
max in only a few months during the
interview he said i know it will be
weird well i've seen the trailer it
seems very familiar he also said miguel
sapochnick who's one of the showrunners
on house of the dragon directed some of
the big episodes in game of thrones so i
have a feeling it will be very surreal
to watch it although it will be a whole
new ensemble from the one nikolai new on
game of thrones he notes that the new
series has an incredible cast i hope
they'll have all the success
now about game of thrones he said i miss
my friends on the show we all became
friends after working together for
nearly a decade i really miss going to
work and seeing the gang and the crew
so as you can see he didn't say a whole
lot during the interview but like i said
earlier i still enjoy reading what they
have to say about working on game of
thrones and or what they think about the
new show house of the dragon i'm sure
once hbo starts releasing the new
episodes everyone from game of thrones
will have a whole lot more to say
and as always i will be here making
videos about everything every step of
the way i hope all of you subscribe and
join me for the ride i want to thank
everyone for watching the video i will
see you again soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you